Salut Romain, il se passe quoi exactement là?
Le peuple gronde Julien.
C'est une manif c'est ça?
Oui! Les gens sont pas contents Julien.
Bah pourquoi?
Les cotons-tiges Julien, les cotons-tiges.
...Ok. J'ai.
"Musique"
Dans ma vidéo sur les oreilles qui sifflent, il y a manifestement un passage qui vous a interpellé
"N'utilisez pas de coton tige", ça vous a fait pas mal réagir !
En même temps c'est vrai, si on peut pas utiliser de coton tige, comment on fait pour se laver les oreilles ?
Eh ben ça, c'est...
La question que tout le monde se pose
Bon alors, prenons le problème à la base: la première question déjà c'est...
pourquoi est ce qu'il faudrait se nettoyer les oreilles, finalement ?
Ben oui, c'est vrai c'est quoi le problème en fait ?
Bon...
Je sais... le problème c'est...
...CÉ ! CÉ ! CÉ ! CÉRUMEN ! ♫
Le cérumen c'est jaune, c'est poisseux... c'est sale quoi.
Ben non. Le cérumen il est utile, il est même super important parce qu'il protège le conduit auditif
et le tympan, il empêche l'eau de rentrer et d'aller trop loin
et il permet d'évacuer un certain nombre de cochonneries, comme des poussières ou des bactéries. Donc, on en a besoin !
Donc faut pas retirer celui qui à l'intérieur de l'oreille, il faut pas aller le chercher !
Enlever celui qui sort de l'oreille et qui est visible de l'extérieur, ça on peut.
C'est même plutôt une bonne idée.
Le problème avec les cotons-tiges, c'est que non seulement ils peuvent abîmer le conduit auditif
et même le tympan si vous êtes vraiment une brute, mais qu'en plus ils poussent une partie du cérumen
dans le fond et que ça peut provoquer des bouchons.
Bon, mais alors comment on nettoie les oreilles ?
Ok.
je vais vous révéler un secret il y a
un moyen il y a même un outil totalement
adapté et absolument parfait pour ça tellement parfait qu'on lui a donné un nom
parfaitement adapté à cette fonction et cet objet c'est:
"Musique"
L'auriculaire,  ben ouais, le petit doigt
littéralement auriculaire
c'est tout ce qui se rapporte à l'oreille
donc vous voyez il y avait un indice.
donc concrètement ce qu'il faut nettoyer c'est le pavillon c'est à dire la partie externe de l'oreille et
l'entrée du conduit mais juste l'entrée pour retirer ce qui coule
et là encore cet objet est extrêmement bien fait parce que il vous suffit de nettoyer
juste là où votre petit doigt peut aller et surtout forcez pas pour essayer d'aller plus loin ça sert à rien
"Hurlement"
Globalement c'est valable pour tous vos orifices
nettoyez l'entrée mais n'allez pas trop loin dans le conduit. Du coup pour vous laver les oreilles quand vous êtes sous la douche
utilisez de l'eau et un peu de savon qui vous voulez vous pouvez aussi faire ça au lavabo dans les mêmes conditions
et vous pouvez même utiliser un petit linge mouillé
si vous avez les ongles longs par exemple alors
on va essayer de vous vendre tout un tas d'autres dispositifs pour vous laver les oreilles comme des bougies d'oreilles par exemple
ouais des bougies à la cire d'abeille qui sont censées
dissoudre et aspirer les bouchons et les résidus de cérumen   .Les rares études menées sur cette technique ont démontré que
non seulement ça marchait pas mais qu'en plus ça pouvait potentiellement être dangereux parce que ça peut laisser des dépôts laissez tomber
sauf si vous vous faites un kiff fétichiste autour du fait d'être un chandelier humain
"Musique"
Il y a aussi les spray nettoyants bon là a priori c'est sans danger mais c'est absolument pas nécessaires au quotidien
le mieux c'est de garder ça pour quand vous ressentez une petite gêne.   Parce que parfois on produit plus de cérumen que d'habitude
alors pour plein de raisons hein trop de poussière un nettoyage trop agressif une inflammation etc ... et parfois aussi on l'évacué moins bien
chez les personnes âgées par exemple
donc dans tous ces cas là ok un petit coup de spray
mais pas systématiquement.
Voilà vous savez maintenant comment vous lavez les oreilles sans coton tige si vous avez d'autres questions
n'hésitez pas à me les poser sur la page facebook de dtc ou par mail à l'adresse
questiondtc@gmail.com DTC C'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve bientôt pour une
nouvelle vidéo d'ici là prenez soin de vous prenez soin de vos oreilles prenez soin des autres
prenez soin de toutes les personnes qui vous importent et de tout ce que vous voulez finalement mettez vous bien et surtout,
portez vous bien.
"Musique"
C'est un beau message d'en revoir voilà